welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series I'm your host Greg
knuckles joined today by a special
temporary guest host eric drexler
eric thanks for joining us thanks so
much for having me on I really
appreciate the opportunity it is my
pleasure
all right let's let's just dive on into
it if this is the first fireside chat
you're listening to this is just fun
off-the-wall light-hearted content not
necessarily Fitness related even though
maybe a Fitness example or allusion will
come up but yeah just two buds chatting
you know on that note I I have noticed
we do tend to gravitate towards somewhat
Fitness e stuff because it's really our
only card to play like like I try to
have non fitness aspects of my life but
I don't yeah I mean same whatever let's
let's just see how this goes we may stop
after like five fireside chats once we
completely exhaust the list of things
we're capable of talking about but for
the time being let's just forge on ahead
let's do it so someone asked us a
question something has gone very wrong
and you're competing in the Miss America
pageant parentheses Congrats on the
state pageant wins closed parenthesis
what is your talent this is your move I
hope you don't mind me stealing it but
you often tend to challenge the premise
of a question correct there is a mr.
America pageant already and as far as I
know that the talent round is basically
two components muscularity and leanness
and so I would say for the mr. America
pageant that's pretty much what I'm
bringing to the table is a symmetrical
physique off-the-charts muscularity and
just absolutely shredded leanness how
about if mr. amer if the mr. America
pageant ran differently in a way that
was perhaps more comparable to the Miss
America pageant what what talent would
you then be bringing to the table that's
a very different scenario but what I
would do almost certainly it has to be
musical so I back in the day I went to a
a school system it was public schools
but there was a bunch of like you know
it's a giant school system a bunch of
like really overachieving kids and so
the band program was very cutthroat very
competitive and I was a percussionist
in the band and I was actually first
chair and so that was something I did
not take lightly so I played the drums
and you know a long list of percussive
instruments but that's where I really
developed my competitive side I think in
eighth grade there was somebody in my
band class who was obsessed with band
and for me it was like a very it was
very far down my list of priorities like
I had football practice every day I love
that band was just like I had to do
something third bell so I'll do band
class but he challenged me you're
allowed to do like head-to-head
percussion battles it was like a rap
battle he would call me out every single
week every week and challenge for the
first chair spot and so I was like every
single week they'd be like alright fine
Eric you gotta learn this new music the
challenge is in one week I have to do it
and like come back and win it and I
swear to god it was every single week
but you know what
props to that guy he may be better at
percussion so thanks for the challenge
as I understand it the film whiplash is
actually loosely biographical and based
on your life during this time period is
that correct I have no idea what that
movie is but I like to think of it more
like drumline with Nick camera that that
somewhere in between the two yeah I I
haven't seen whiplash I just know that
it exists is it basically the same thing
as drumline it's uh you know I don't
know any of the actors names but it's uh
it's hangin what is that guy's name ball
dude he plays jonah Jameson in the old
spider-man films no I whatever anyway
he's like an [ __ ] jazz band
instructor and there's this kid who's
trying to get really good at at jazz
drumming and it's like a very abusive
like mentor mentee relationship yeah
that's that's literally all I know about
the movie Lindsey
was watching it on an airplane one time
and so I was kind of like looking over
and so that's what I into it that it's
about just based on kind of like the
facial expressions and body language of
the actors yes so that's probably not at
all what it's about but I was trying to
come across as cultured I think I think
the critics liked that one pretty close
I I did get to have the generic like
GarageBand experience though like if you
play the drums you have to write yeah so
there was one time me and my buddies who
actually like some of them were like
very skilled musicians we played a
battle of the bands in a laser tag
facility oh well you can't get more
GarageBand than that and dude our band
was awesome like everybody else played
this like absolute garbage genre of
music we came out there we played a jimi
hendrix song hey Joe we played a
heart-shaped box by Nirvana and we threw
a Radiohead tune in there like we got to
play three tracks and we covered a
spectrum it was sick we were not even
close to winning but I thought we did
the best who did you have in your band
at that age who was capable of playing
Hendrix actually so our guitarist is a
he he got a very coveted scholarship to
a music conservatory I think that's what
they call it but like a really really
prestigious music school and he plays
jazz guitar professionally but but he
was an exceptionally skilled guitarist
that is super cool yeah so that's what I
mean like for me it was like oh yeah I
was in this little GarageBand but like
one of us was actually like a insanely
talented musician so yeah he carried a
lot of weight here's the fact most
people don't know about me I was in a
band for one weekend how did that go so
I played a little guitar and had a buddy
who was a bassist had another friend who
was a drummer
none of us could sing worth anything
whatsoever right just absolutely
tone-deaf and terrible the drummer was
dating this girl who who was quite a
good singer like she had she had a
really good singing voice had stage
experience like we thought she would be
a good front woman for the band like you
know you know be able to to bring the
inner
on stage so we got together we we jammed
twice over the course of a weekend yeah
and then the drummer and the lead singer
broke up and we just didn't care enough
to try to find another singer that's
tragic you know that it is a good point
cuz every like high school Garage Band
is like dude who the hell is gonna sing
yeah so me and those two buddies one of
which is like a professional guitarist
now we were in this class where you base
it was like an eighth grade or freshman
year or something but you learned how to
use like Microsoft Word and by the way
none of it counts anymore word changed
to a new version all the stuff we
learned is done it was like Word and
Excel and PowerPoint and all that the
the Windows 95 version I forget what but
whatever it is it's all outdated mm-hmm
but they taught us all these cool tips
and tricks and stuff but there was this
kid in our class
very mysterious kid rambled into town
nobody knew where he came from
he was like an older kid we didn't
really know how he was in our class but
this kid just kind of appeared out of
nowhere mm-hmm was in our band for like
three months and then just like kind of
drifted his way out of town it was oh it
was like a fictitious character I'm
still not certain that the kid actually
existed but he like rambled in and then
just rambled out and it's like the
memories are so vague at this point I'm
like what was that all about like where
did he go where did he come from but he
had an incredible voice so he just kind
of rambled in we did a battle of the
bands and then he rambled out that's
awesome yeah I moved on with his life so
my my skill
if mr. America finally opened up and
would have some some talent rounds that
would be mine would be the the drumming
and percussion what about you sir
so I would go for a strategy that has
previously paid off for me before and if
if the person against whom this strategy
works is listening to this I'm probably
gonna get some some pretty nasty emails
or Facebook messages in response okay
but uh so back in high school I ran for
student body president there was only
one other person running and the way
that the
like campaigning worked essentially is
you know you could hang up posters and
whatnot around the school but we had
like a homeroom period and there were
TVs in all of the all of the homeroom
classrooms and so like we each prepared
a little pitch to say like this is why
you should vote for me for student body
president like ultimately it doesn't
matter we had absolutely no did your
authority whatsoever so there's there's
not that much you can you can pitch as
far as like student body presidents
services ago and so I was aware of that
and for whatever reason they like
recorded mine first and they were gonna
broadcast both of them during the same
homeroom period and they assumed like
you know these kids aren't gonna put
much time and effort into putting
together stump speeches and like I
didn't but I did put some time and
energy into essentially preparing a
comedy routine that lasted for the
entirety of homeroom period and so that
I was the only person that people were
aware of as being on the ballot and like
they started running her little pitch
during the last like two minutes of
homeroom and then like when class
changes started and so I essentially won
by default because there was another
name on the ballot but like she never
had the ability to to put herself in
front of the people which you know in my
defense they could have reviewed those
two videos and decided to roll hers
first but I kind of rolled the dice
there I was like maybe I can just win by
default and that's essentially how it
went and so I think for my talent in the
mr. America pageant I would try to use
the same tack and my talent would be
baking bread because depending on you
know what kind of leavening you're using
how much the ambient temperature of the
room what kind of bread you're making
etc that's gonna take anywhere between
like four and 24 hours give or take
so yeah like people would go before me
in the pageant obviously and then when
my talent segment came up that would be
the end of the pageant like I would be
the last thing that that the judges
would see and as long as that loaf was
good that would be the last memory of
the pageant in their minds it could
completely backfire so they could say
hey this guy completely ruined the event
there's no way he can win but it you
know it would be one of those Hail Mary
plays that may or may not pay off you
know I have a real-life story of a Hail
Mary play that did pay off I was doing
an essay competition one time and there
were like some pretty high stakes like
for winning in terms of like college
ramifications and I didn't know who was
going to be judging these essays but I
you had to pick one of the three prompts
from the front of the sheet and one of
the three from the back so you're
writing two essays in a given timeframe
and it was timed it was like you
couldn't think of it beforehand and I
looked at the prompts and I immediately
made a decision I am going to write one
of them as the most light-hearted
frivolous carefree pieces you could ever
read very fun
the other one was dark I mean it was it
was dark and my gamble was if the same
person grades both or scores both
they're either gonna think I am a
lunatic and immediately disqualify me or
they're gonna say this kids got range
and I ended up winning one of the one of
the like pretty big things from that
essay competition so so it paid off but
I was like man somebody's either gonna
be really impressed or just downright
concern for me when they read this it
was pretty awesome
so I I did something similar in middle
school so it wasn't an essay competition
there wasn't really anything on the line
but there was a speech competition where
there was you know like a class-wide
thing and then a school-wide thing and
then a countywide thing and the
countywide thing I mean like ultimately
it doesn't matter we were in we were in
[ __ ] like six or seventh grade
nothing we had to say at that time
period in our lives had any value
whatsoever but it was one of those
things where the well-to-do people in
the community were going to come out to
you know support the kids who are trying
to learn how to do public speaking and
and do well for themselves and whatnot
and so and there was like a different
prompt for each one so one the class
competition one the school competition
for the countywide competition the the
prompt was like something related to
freedom of speech and at that time so I
grew up in in a very small rural town we
had one high school the high school was
built in the 50s and it was just
tragically overcrowded so it was built
for I want to say eight nine hundred
students and and so like the county
itself had a fair amount of people like
part of the county was a suburb
essentially for a larger city but like
my my little part of it was super tiny
but the high school itself like I said
was built for about eight hundred people
and then by the time I was going through
I think my freshman year it had like
2200 students so it was way over
capacity we needed a new high school but
you know the way that the county was
proposing to raise the money for that
high school was by increasing either the
the county sales tax by like half a cent
or imposing like a quarter of a percent
land tax something like that and so like
as elections go you know it's mostly
like the fairly old people voting
especially in county elections and they
made sure that the voting process didn't
coincide with like a big general or even
midterm election when turnout would be
high like they made sure that it was
taking place at just like random times
in random years where they could ensure
that turnout would be pretty low and so
the the bond to raise the money for the
new school kept getting voted down and
at some point during that process we
like I don't know if this was like a
broader initiative or just like
something we did in our classroom but we
all wrote letters into the local
newspaper about why we thought like
there should or shouldn't be another
high school so I think this was seventh
grade so we were already thinking like
okay we're gonna be going to high school
in a couple years do we want to be going
to a new high school or the same old
like 1950s super rundown high school and
so the the general vibe I think among
all of us was yeah we want a new high
school like the current one like the
facilities are garbage and so we all
wrote into the newspaper and you know
this is small town so like the local
newspaper was how people disseminated
information like social media definitely
doesn't exist yet and so you know every
week the newspaper would come we'd look
at the letters to the editor section
they didn't publish any of our letters
they didn't publish any letters from
anyone under like 58 years old and so
for so to circle back to the original
story for the prom for like the
countywide speech competition it was
something related to freedom of speech
and so I remember my whole thing was
like look freedom of speech means that
the government's not going to prosecute
you for whatever you say but ultimately
for your speech to to get out and like
reach people and again keep in mind this
was before social media it was like
there are people who turned the levers
of power that have platforms that ensure
you know what speech gets stifled in
what speech gets amplified and so like
that was in Davie County that was the
local newspaper and that was it and so I
knew the editor-in-chief of the
newspaper would be at that countywide
speech competition because that was just
like the kind of thing he would go to
and so I just went like straight
scorched earth on the Davie County
Enterprise in the speech competition
with him in the audience and I just
stared at him the whole time and he came
up afterwards and said that was very
compelling if a little bit uncomfortable
and the very next week he published my
letter that's pretty cool
yeah yeah props to the editor there yeah
he was so I mean like you know keep in
mind I'm like I'm like 13 years old I
didn't know the guy and I had this image
of him is just like you know this just
complete [ __ ] who like you were
living out the lyrics of a Rage Against
the Machine song yeah yeah yeah
and I mean I do think I had a point cuz
ultimately like the kids going to the
high school they weren't like we weren't
going to be paying a significant portion
of the sales tax and certainly not a
significant portion of the land tax I
would be raised in the county but like
we were the people who are about to go
to the high school and we're going to be
affected by whether there was a new
school or not so I did think that it was
like a little shitty that that none of
us got to make our opinion heard at
least publicly but anyway yeah he ended
up being super chill about it very cool
now we are about to move on to our next
topic here but but Greg I understand
some things that you said in a previous
episode have kind of started generating
some controversy and you want an
opportunity to get out ahead of that
controversy right there has been some
controversy regarding the pop-tart
ravioli situation mm-hmm a few people
have written in indicating that they in
fact think both of them are
subcategories of strudels mm-hmm and I
would like to counter that by saying
that they all fall like now that I've
had some more time to think about it I
think they all fall within the greater
empanada family Wow
so so anyway just you know I I hear your
criticism and I just think we should all
keep an open mind about that that's a
good point
man that that adds another layer to that
it really does that discussion Wow okay
so the next topic we have here someone
asked us and this is a topic that's near
and dear to probably both of our hearts
certainly mind how and when did we
transition from bro science to
evidence-based when it comes to our
general fitness outlook or our Fitness
approach do you want to start with this
one or should I
I just told a really long story so I
think you should lead this one off yeah
so like a lot of people I kind of
started out in Fitness with the muscle
magazines and for the younger people
that are listening a magazine was
basically a package of written materials
with a lot of glossy pages but I started
out with the muscle magazines and
actually I'm pretty sure the one that I
used to read a lot actually just like
stopped printing recently which is
devastating
we're like approaching dinosaur age
somehow already like industries we grew
up with they're done yeah but but anyway
started out with the muscle magazines
and then started branching out into
other online sources and if you do that
eventually you're gonna run into some
contradictions and you know when you're
just getting everything from a singular
magazine with one editing team you're
you're pretty much getting a decently
consistent narrative in most cases but
once you start branching out you have to
run into some uncomfortable questions
like what do we know about fitness how
do we know what we know and how well do
we actually know that we know what we
know and as you start getting into those
questions eventually it's gonna lead you
to science like that that's pretty much
the whole the whole purpose if you were
to kind of boil it down is like figuring
out what we know how we know it and how
confident we are in knowing that once
you become cognizant of the fact that
epistemology exists like that even if
you don't know the term and before we
move on do you mind just giving us a
very simple definition of epistemology
philosophy of knowledge from what does
it mean to know things how can we know
things right how can we reliably come to
know things about the world exactly yeah
you start saying okay I need to figure
out where I'm getting my information and
how how reliable how credible this
information is and so and by what
standard can you judge
exactly yeah so I think it was kind of a
natural very gradual transition into
that evident evidence-based approach and
I mean this took place I first started
like reading through the muscle
magazines when I was like probably 16
and I wouldn't say I really was super
focused on the evidence-based side of
things until I was like 20 it was a very
very gradual thing but what I noticed
was after making that transition there
were a few distinct phases of that you
know becoming evidence-based transition
so the first phase was that of the
mythbuster or the debunker you know so
it was basically like you had been fed
this bill of goods for all these years
you thought you knew everything about
fitness turns out most of it was just
like slick marketing and for that first
phase you basically are lay and also the
the USDA and the food guide pyramid are
trying to kill you yes that bad as well
I think everyone went through that phase
I think so it's just like guess what
saturated fat isn't going to murder you
but whole grains will yeah
so like down with the government like
CDC is in in the pocket of big big sugar
or whatever yeah I definitely went
through that phase yeah yeah I think
like you just go overboard on the
skepticism yeah once you realize
skepticism is allowed yeah you're like
yeah so some in that phase it's like you
kind of become this know-it-all who's
like hyper skeptical skeptical about
everything but not particularly helpful
yeah like you can tell them people a
million things they're doing that aren't
helpful but then if they're like yeah
can you tell me something that is you're
like I'm not really that interested in
that and also just like the general
posture of like oh it's coming from
these so-called experts probably
[ __ ] exactly yeah yeah so so it was
like a pretty superficial level of
understanding engaging with content at a
very superficial level but at least
trying to access more reliable
information then the second phase for me
happened end of undergrad beginning of
grad school when I actually
found out I didn't know anything at all
like when you start digging deeper into
the like the methods behind the finding
the first phase is to realize oh god I
need to learn a lot of things very
quickly and so then there's that
learning phase where you actually really
doubt your your interpretation of stuff
and then the next phase which is in my
opinion the good phase is that of a
translational facilitator so the whole
idea is turning research findings into
actionable helpful conclusions so it's
not just being some know-it-all who
dunks on people on the internet when
they say that they used a stupid
supplement because I went through that
phase not a good phase but I think a lot
of people have to unfortunately pass
through it at some point but but that's
really like the goal is getting to that
phase where you can turn research
findings into good helpful
recommendations that are actually useful
and when you get to that phase you
realize that every conclusion you draw
it's not just a conclusion it comes with
a level of confidence in the conclusion
and it also comes with a level of
importance so when you get to that phase
that kind of step of the journey you
notice that the advice you're giving is
a lot more nuanced because it's always
the conclusion plus the confidence level
plus the how much does it really matter
level as well and so I'd like to believe
that I've settled in there but really
you kind of continuously oscillate
between the last two right where you
feel really good about a certain area
but there are still areas where you're
like I really don't know anything at all
and and so that I think now it's just
kind of trying to be helpful trying to
be useful and translate stuff that
actually you know it's not just dunking
on people on the internet it's not just
myth-busting but it's actually creating
helpful stuff but then continuing to get
better at those areas where you're still
in that second stage of like wow I have
a lot of blind spots in this specific
topic yeah yeah but but yeah I mean I
guess that that was kind of my my
general transition and the reason for it
was completely selfish you know it was I
wanted to get as big as a human could
feasibly do
and and I was like well I better figure
out the right way to do it you know it
was completely self-serving I want the
information I want all the good stuff
and so that's why I started kind of
branching out into different different
areas of information was just I don't
want the slick marketing I want to know
what's gonna work to get me as big and
strong as as humanly possible that makes
sense so what about you
so I think I think that the broad
contours of kind of my journey are
similar to yours I think I think the
beginning of it is a little bit
different so my kind of my first
flirtation with epistemology was of a
very well what's a good word like a very
reluctant flirtation so I mentioned
something on the first fireside chat and
that is that I was raised in a like
fundamentalist young earth creationist
household I think a lot of people
thought that was a joke that wasn't a
joke no that that's not and another
thing to know is that I grew up in
tobacco country and so like there was a
multi-decade information war between
r.j. Reynolds and Philip Morris and like
the scientific establishment about
whether cigarettes cause cancer and you
know within the community I grew up that
was that was seen as far from a settled
question and keep in mind this is like
the 90s this is this is when the
question had been settled for like two
decades at that point it was still like
I can't really trust the government
can't really trust science like they say
in cigarettes are bad but our entire
economy runs on cigarettes kind of like
prison or our entire economy runs on
cigarettes so can they really be that
bad can we really believe that they're
that bad so anyway I have like very deep
skepticism and mistrust of science in
general from both of those
two things both like kind of growing up
so it was weird so I was dealing with a
lot of what's it called when when you're
holding contradictory ideas and your
heads I yeah yeah so so Michael
childhood was just like in ocean of
cognitive dissonance cuz yeah you know
we weren't Luddites like we used modern
technology like clearly science helped
that be developed like my parents
believed in modern medicine they weren't
like crazy anti-vaxxers or anything like
that so like on one hand obviously a lot
of science is good and useful and
created the modern world but then
clearly like some of it is just like
utter and complete [ __ ] right so so
like that was the the tension within
young Greg's brain we're basically like
is science a force for good in progress
or is it evil and bad and you can't
trust any of it and so I think like
before I could before I could come up to
the epistemological answer of hey
science is good and useful I had to I
had to eventually settle on Sciences
trustworthy and not fundamentally evil
and so like that was that was its whole
process and then once I finally arrived
on hey guess what science is fine then
it became a process of you know how can
I access and understand and interpret
science I don't really go through a big
muscle mag fees my so I lifted weights
for a while and just kind of trusted the
biggest guy in the gym and then when I
started trying to seek out information
it was when I started taking things more
seriously and getting into powerlifting
and so I was like super into Westside
for a few years and Louis Simmons
writing at least gives the very strong
veneer that its scientific so you know
Soviet sports science was like light
years ahead of ours and like
these texts that he cites all the time
that purport to be scientific and so I I
trusted that that was a like reliable
relaying of scientific information and
then like eventually I started becoming
exposed to other sources also on the
internet and started becoming like a
little bit more skeptical of both like
Westside stuff but more so just like
Soviet sports science in general because
a lot of it was never actually published
it was just kind of like it was kind of
like blogging really like coaches would
train people and like they were
successful in doing so
and then they just like write it up for
a periodical and say like hey did this
with my athletes seemed to work and like
that's the majority of Soviet sports
science like there's it's it's not
something we would recognize as a
scientific method it was it was series
of case studies at best yeah yeah so
yeah basically I just learned more about
how the scientific process actually
works and then like gravitated to other
sources who were relating like more
modern scientific information and then
started reading stuff for myself and
then I basically the the last the last
two phases you talked about or that's
like the exact same progression I took
so yeah that's that's my story I think I
think they're broadly similar journeys
just differing in terms of where they
started like how how fundamentally
skeptical we were of science to begin
with yeah now one of the things that
kind of goes hand-in-hand with that
topic right so I mentioned there's that
kind of know-it-all phase that usually
results in a lot of arguing on the
internet or at the very least trying to
dunk on people on the Internet
I feel like whenever you're in areas
where people discuss a lot of you know
evidence based fitness stuff there's a
lot of people trying to change people's
minds and so someone asked us some
questions related to changing people's
minds I
remember exactly how the question was
phrased it was just kind of a topic of
what do you think about changing
people's minds or something like that so
why don't you start out with this one
because I think your answer is gonna be
better than mine yeah so this is
something that so if you if you follow
me online you probably think that this
is something I'm trying to do often and
like I'm not so I I view what I do in
terms of Public Communication so putting
out the podcast writing articles for the
website you know communicating on social
media I don't really set out to change
people's minds and it would kind of like
I think it would be nice if I did but
that's not something that I'm too
interested in or particularly trying to
do so essentially if someone is
receptive to what I'm saying then either
like I can teach them new things or if
someone is already kind of receptive to
having their mind change like if they
believe one thing and I'm saying
something else but they weren't already
clinging very strongly to that initial
belief and are already in a state that
being presented with evidence could
change their mind then I'm happy to
change their mind but I think a lot of
people go into especially writing about
controversial subjects with you know my
goal here is to write an article or make
a video or whatever that's going to like
convert these people that have different
beliefs from mine and that will be good
I don't I don't try to do that because I
don't think that it's particularly
effective in terms of public
communication I think that for the most
part if you're going to change people's
minds with public communication it's
almost always people who were already
receptive to having their minds be
changed because they weren't cleaned to
their initial belief super strongly in
the first place if you're talking about
changing people's minds and like
dislodging a deeply held belief and you
know substituting a new one with it then
that almost always has to take place
with just non-threatening one-on-one
private communication it's gonna be for
most people it's going to be almost like
too threatening to have that
conversation in public and they'll
they'll probably just have too many
defenses built up against your
generalized data based arguments that
you throw at them so in it can even work
in Reverse so there's a phenomenon
called the backfire effect or is it the
blowback effect I think it's the
backfire effect one of the two where if
people already believe something and you
present them with evidence that what
they believed was in fact false they
actually wind up believing the thing
that they initially believed even
stronger because it's generally not
sufficient to change their minds and
then they'll kind of like develop
immunity to those arguments who are
trying to put forth and like try to
develop counter arguments against them
and they just wind up believing the
initial thing even stronger now that I
think about it the backfire effect may
have been a casualty of the replication
crisis I'm not totally sure about that
but I'm pretty sure the state of the
research as it stands now is either the
backfire effect is a thing or just that
present presenting people with facts
doesn't really change their mind one way
or the other like it may not necessarily
make them more recalcitrant and their
prior beliefs but it certainly doesn't
seem to do a ton to change their minds
unless their minds were already open to
being changed and so I think mostly it's
gonna have to take place with just
private one-on-one communication I think
a Socratic approach is generally fairly
effective
so most of the things we believe you me
everyone else we don't take a ton of
time and energy to audit our beliefs and
check like why do I believe this what
evidence do I have supporting it what
gaps do I have in
my you know in in the support that I
have for this thing is like the
foundational ideas underpinning this big
belief that I have like we don't do that
because that's it takes time it's not
like a fun crazy stimulating thing so
like I think something that's useful is
to start with like oh okay so you
believe this thing like why is that
and some people may not be open to
answering questions at all like that
that in and of itself could come across
as threatening and if that is the case
you're probably not going to change
their mind in the first place like
they're just not open to it at all and
changing people's minds is very much
like a it takes two to tango situation
you're not going to change someone's
mind purely because you were so
convincing with a particular idea they
have to be open to it like they have to
be a a willing recipient to the
arguments you're putting forth
you can't just destroy them with facts
and logic correct okay and so yeah if
someone's you know willing to answer a
few questions trying to take a few steps
back and say like okay you believe this
well why is that and they'll probably
have pretty good reasons at that first
level of introspection it's like okay
well you know why do you believe that
what evidence do you have supporting
this idea that's one layer down and like
that'll probably be good once you get
like three or four layers down maybe
things are gonna start looking shaky and
they might start realizing them on their
own they're like oh like the the
foundational ideas underpinning this
thing I believe maybe aren't as strong
as I thought they were so that's that's
one useful tack to try to take where you
know you're trying to get them to
realize for themselves that maybe they
don't have great reasons to believe what
they believe without you telling them
that it's wrong you know another thing
that that I think is important for for
any discussion whether it's trying to
change minds are just like any
conversation that might turn out kind of
like debate II or combative is
just start it by making sure like you
and the other person are coming to the
discussion with similar underlying
assumptions and that you agree generally
about standards of evidence so like if
if I'm trying to change someone's mind
into them like a conspiracy theorist
youtube-channel matters just as much as
a published meta-analysis I don't know
where to go from there you know what I
mean like they they now are willing to
enter into the discussion untold
mountains of completely [ __ ]
information that they believe completely
uncritically and you know you you could
support any belief if if those are the
standards of evidence you're willing to
use and so you know first off try to set
not like ground rules but just to make
sure you have similar assumptions about
you know what do we know about the world
what can we know about the world how can
we go about finding out reliable
information about the world if and again
if there's huge differences of opinion
about that it may just not be a very
fruitful conversation in the first place
unless you want to take 30 steps back
and say like let's go to epistemology
class together which like that
conversation is probably not going to
get off the ground in the first place
and then okay so make sure you have
similar core assumptions and similar
standards of evidence another thing that
I think is pretty important is to make
sure you're trying to change change
people's minds about well it's probably
gonna go better if you're having a
discussion about facts rather than about
values because two people can look at
the same the same set of facts and have
have different values and so they come
away with completely different ideas
about what to do with those facts and
and bringing more information into that
discussion ultimately isn't going to
move it forward so for example I know
that these are supposed to be fun
hearted little discussions oh and I am
going to to dwell on this topic for the
shortest amount of time possible but
it's the first thing that came to mind
okay so you know let's take the abortion
debate okay so for some people they they
believe very strongly that life begins
at conception and so like you know if
you're then going to argue that like oh
but like they're not feeling pain
because the nervous system doesn't
develop until such-and-such a day or
like the brain isn't developed enough to
like interpret those nerve signals until
like such-and-such a day that doesn't
matter like there's there's a different
value like there's a different value
system there and there's a different
underlying assumption about when life
begins and how to respond to that so
like ultimately I don't think that
that's I don't think that's a discussion
that science is ever going to to settle
in a way that's gonna satisfy everyone
engaged in that debate yeah so I think
that that's like an archetypal example
of you know two people can can have
access to the same facts believe
strongly in the same facts but their
values are just so different that they
come to very very different conclusions
about what to do yeah they're not
debating facts of like the chronological
timeline of embryo development or you
know development so so getting more into
those details is not necessarily going
to settle that for them basically what
your waiter yeah yeah so and dude if
you're trying to change people's minds
about a question of values then you have
to take 30 steps back and be like how
comfortable are you with re-evaluating
your entire worldview right and I can
tell you the answer to that question for
99% of people is not very [ __ ]
comfortable so that conversation is just
probably not gonna go anywhere and then
another piece of advice I would give is
like you want the conversation to be as
non-threatening as possible and you
shouldn't try to push someone to agree
with
you you know within the same
conversation within the same week within
the same month you want it to be you
want it to be as non-threatening a space
as possible and you shouldn't expect
people to change their minds immediately
sometimes it is just a situation where
someone where you and that person have
similar underlying assumptions similar
standards of evidence they were exposed
to bad information you're like oh well
actually turns out there's been more
research on this topic you're just not
up to date with the research which like
is fine no one's up to date with all
research all the time here's what the
current data is suggesting they're like
oh okay well I was wrong about this
thing that's cool and like that exchange
can take place very quickly
that's not how changing people's minds -
tends to go like it's usually dozens of
conversations spread out over months and
they very gradually come around to your
way of seeing things or to make this
clear
it could be the opposite could turn out
that you're trying to change their mind
and you're just asked backwards and like
your mind slowly changes over time but
yeah don't expect it to be immediate and
don't push the person and try to force
it to be immediate they're probably just
gonna recoil and that'll in the
discussion like you said that is
something you see sometimes where
someone in the process of trying to
change someone else's mind mm-hmm they
have to basically make that pitch yeah
for their belief and in the process of
kind of finally writing out that whole
like here's the entire reason why you
should believe it sometimes a person
will actually change their own thought
about it and be like wow now that I've
made this case I don't think my case is
that strong yeah yeah so it can be a
pretty productive constructive thing
sometimes that's really for sure and
that's actually the last thing I wanted
to say which is like it's not gonna go
anywhere unless everyone in the
discussion which again ideally this is
private so ideally it's the two people
in the discussion are both you know
discussing it in good faith if you're if
you view it as
I know I'm right I'm attacking this idea
and the only positive way that this
discussion can end is they now agree
with me you're not going into that
discussion with good faith like you want
the other person to be discussing it in
good faith but if that's how you're
going into it you are not discussing it
in good faith and I think people kind of
pick up on that vibe and sort of shut
down so you know you need to make sure
that they're open to their mind being
changed that it's not just a completely
recalcitrant idea that they're not
willing to examine further and you also
need to make sure that that is true for
yourself you know just so you're going
into it on an even playing field and
you're not having a discussion in bad
faith because that's that's very common
and I think I kind of think if someone's
asking the question of how can I change
people's minds they and I'm not trying
to call out the individual who asked
this question but just kind of the
general you know the general mood of
like hey I want to convince people of
things I want tips on how to do that
better the underlying assumption there
is probably I know I'm right about
particular things and I know a lot of
people around me are wrong about those
particular things so you know teach me
hacks and tricks to get everyone around
me to agree with me that's not how you
should be approaching this like it's
more about how to have a productive
discussion and in good faith with other
individuals yeah you mentioned like that
that step of like let's make sure the
other person is actually open to
potentially changing their mind I think
a lot of people don't realize it but
they go into that kind of conversation
and the way they're mentally viewing it
is will you commit to being open to me
helping you become correct right you
know but they have an absolutely no
openness to actually change their own
opinion you know but do you have
anything else to add on the topic I
think that's it okay so my answer is
gonna be far shorter than yours because
I I agree with everything you said
previously so I don't I don't want to be
repetitive but I do think it's really
funny if you just kind of loosely follow
evidence-based fitness on social media
the the course that this usually takes
is someone has a belief that is like
literally part of their identity
it's in their screen name or hair like
their Twitter handle you know what I
mean and someone says like I would like
to talk you out of that that very big
key thing of your identity not only will
you have to change your beliefs you'll
have to change your Twitter handle
exactly and yeah I did get rid of your
website because that that won't count
anymore once you change your opinion we
clearly have different values regarding
levels of evidence and in order to make
this nice and private let's do it on a
third party's YouTube channel you know
it's it's it's it's always just like you
look at the way this thing's brewing and
it's like a perfect storm of doing
everything wrong and it's like the only
value there maybe you could argue hey
someone will be able to watch a good
argument and a bad argument happened
maybe yeah but but no I mean in terms of
that actually being like a constructive
thing to do you're just like oh you can
see it from a mile away you're like
they're going to maybe just kind of talk
over each other or they'll do the other
thing which is they show up in front of
a microphone and all of a sudden they're
like extremely cordial and polite and
like don't even talk about the stuff
they disagree about and then as soon as
they get off they're just like this
[ __ ] what a dumbass yeah so
evidence-based fitness is not the place
when it especially like the nutrition
Wars oh my god like some of these diets
I mean they are built into people's
identities you know that that's one of
the reasons that we brought you on if
I'm being completely transparent because
it's just like one I know what I look
like I'm not the guy to talk about
nutrition in the first place but second
it's like you know I could inform myself
about these things and wade into those
waters and offer opinions but I don't
want to you know like I am sure one of
these days you're going to write
something about nutrition and it is
going to garner in order
magnitude more ire then I could possibly
garner by saying literally anything
about training yeah that that is
definitely true but the only thing I
would add to your answer is when it
comes to you know basically convincing
people of things are changing people's
minds one piece of advice I have to add
on top of of everything you mentioned is
I think people generally should be a
little bit more selective about when
they need to I think I think you see a
lot where where people feel compelled
more than they should like I need to
talk everyone into thinking exactly what
I think about this
mm-hm and you know I'm not downplaying
the fact sometimes it is important you
know sometimes you will see someone
doing something that is immediately
detrimental to their health like a
dangerous thing that they are doing and
in that case you could say hey I kind of
feel a responsibility to at least say
hey I'm really worried about what you're
doing here you know what I mean like
yeah like if they're burning styrofoam
and hanging over the flames and huffing
the smoke because it strengthens the
lungs right yeah for example I mean
there's I hope no one does that I hope
not but but I mean you will every now
and then see somebody be like oh I'm
gonna do this crazy nutrition challenge
and you're like dude you might die or
I'm not gonna vaccinate my kids smallpox
isn't that bad yeah so there are
instances I'm not saying like hey
everyone mind your own business and
never never chime in on anything but but
I do think it's valuable before you
engage in something that's gonna drain a
lot of your time and energy and get you
emotionally invested in a conversation
that's gonna be immensely frustrating
and bring nothing but negativity to your
day maybe think about like the things
you mentioned is this an endeavor that
is worth beginning
is it worth embarking on this mission to
to convince this person of something
knowing that it either isn't that
important doesn't affect me whatsoever
and or there's no way they're ever gonna
change their mind on this yeah so so I
think one of the things that would
really
dramatically improved the discourse when
it comes to evidence-based fitness would
be if people were a little bit more
selective on exactly when they felt
compelled to really dunk on people on
the internet and be like I need you to
agree with me on this and it gets it
tends to get vitriolic it tends to just
become really negative pretty quickly so
I think mutton the only thing I have a
dad is like think about it before you
eat before you enter that space and say
like yep it's really critical that I
convince everybody of this thing think
about how important it is but also think
about your likelihood of success like
just for sure yeah if nothing else just
for your own sanity and productivity
like you ever see someone that's like
dude you you clearly have put like 72
hours into this conversation and you are
not gonna get anywhere near where you
want to there was an epic thread about
polyunsaturated fatty acids on oh man
aware of it I think I don't remember for
sure but I think it was this guy named
Tom McDonald I think it was on something
he posted and I don't remember who the
primary combatant in this situation was
but there was some dude who just thought
that like poof azar are poison and that
dude that Facebook thread the last I saw
of it I want to say it had 22,000
comments yeah and like a third of them
were this one dude and and you know
probably there were a few other people
who were like in the Pro or neutral PUFA
camp who were who were also probably
each responsible for about a tenth of
the Commons in that thread but like dude
yeah there were people who clearly
invested dozens if not hundreds of hours
of their life into that and I'm sure no
one's mind was changed about anything
yeah now the last thing I will say is
one of the things I think you and I have
in common is that we really don't worry
too much about like we're very
comfortable letting other people do what
they want to do like live how you want
to live think what you want to think
it's generally okay with me as long as
you're not hurting any
yeah so in line with that like if you
just really love chatting about this
stuff with people and kind of getting
into some of these discussions I'm not
saying you shouldn't but what what I
hate is when people clearly are like
bringing a lot of just absolute
negativity and frustration into their
own life unwittingly it's like dude it
if you love doing it do it like that's
fine you know we want you to do whatever
whatever keeps you happy whatever makes
you have fun just don't be like super
mean and vitriolic and stuff but but
yeah I just for a lot of people I'm like
just you don't seem to be getting any
joy from this and you're not talking
anyone into anything yeah so like maybe
just reconsider how often you need to do
this so I can tell you what I personally
do yeah so like I said at the top of
this topic in terms of public
communication that is you know solely
directed at people who you know may
weakly disagree with my perspective but
who are open to their minds being
changed you read it I convinced you cool
that's nice
people who you know don't have a belief
about a particular topic and are just
trying to be informed about it you know
that's that's kind of who I primarily
write to and occasionally I'll write an
argumentative piece that's like hey you
probably believe this thing I kind of
don't think that's correct and those
tend to be my longest articles outside
of like squat bench deadlift guides
because I do try to be as as polite
about things as possible where it's just
like you know here are some things you
you probably believe you probably have
very good reasons for believing them
they're very reasonable things for
someone to believe and try to present
their view as charitably as possible
before saying like and there's you know
a different way of looking at this I
definitely don't think you're dumb for
believing something different but you
know let's just look at it but but I
very very rarely even attempt to do that
and then in terms of like commenting on
stuff
I'm the drive-by dude where like I don't
know I'm like if I see someone's if I
see someone's Twitter handle is like car
or care and I'm not gonna say anything
but you know if I see someone post the
status or like in a common thread and
they say something I generally disagree
with I will give them two comments to
test the waters where I'll you know type
something up say like hey like I see
what you're saying here here's some
counter evidence potentially worth
considering and then you know if they
respond in a very upset way I'm just
like okay have a nice day if they say
like oh cool I wasn't aware of this
information
Thanks then it's like okay cool have a
nice day that was positive or if they
say like oh that's interesting here here
are a couple follow-up questions then
like I'll answer that and then if it
seems like I'm they're trying to get me
sucked into a debate I'm like nope have
a nice day or if they're like oh okay
cool that's that's what I wanted to know
thank you very much then that's the end
of that discussion I used to get sucked
into a lot of arguments on social media
and it's like you were saying just it
was a complete waste of my time in the
time of everyone else who was involved
in those discussions so yeah like now if
I very very rarely will I see someone
who seems to have a very entrenched
belief and say like okay time to go
after it and and like I was saying when
I do that I'm not I'm not thinking I can
lob a bomb in change of mind it's
essentially just like okay I'm probably
hung Creedon for somewhere between two
and maybe a dozen cumulative hours of
conversation with this person and then
that may still not make any progress
whatsoever see I'm very judicious about
attempting to do that that this made me
think of last thing I want to say about
the topic we talked on a previous
fireside chat about the thing like our
pet peeves the things that that get us
to be a bit more curmudgeonly than
normal one of the things that has
happened to me only a few times but it
really grinds my gears is sometimes
someone will reach out to me
and ask my my opinion on a topic and
then like insist on like no Eric you're
having an argument with me now dude that
drives me so insane because like what
I'll do is I'll try to be like you know
I'll be like okay well I'll give my
opinion I'll give some justification for
it right and then they might push back
on I'd be like oh well they want some
clarification of course I'm happy to
clarify and I'll give more and but then
there's that little point in the
conversation when you notice oh no
they're arguing with me until I change
my mind and there's no way for me to get
out of this and at that point I'm like
okay this is insane
you know like that drives me absolutely
nuts yeah and then I just leave the
argument I'm sorry I I gave you my my
opinion the justification and the
clarification if you disagree I wish you
the best of luck no I certainly agree
with with that and I should be very
clear you know I mentioned that this
general thing does kind of grind my
gears and get me a little bit grumpy it
doesn't mean that I'm angry at the
person doing it so if you're listening
along and you're thinking oh Eric
probably hates me now not at all the
case but every now and then people will
try to drag me into an argument that I
don't want to be in and I don't hold it
against them I don't get angry at them
but I do basically rapidly excuse myself
from the argument that I think that I
had no intention of entering all right
one topic that people have been asking
us to talk about a topic that's
important to both of us and that would
be beer who do you think should kick
this off I can kick it off it looks like
you have more on the outline yeah I do
all right so I like beer just in general
there are a few Styles that I
particularly enjoy and I don't
necessarily drink them all that often
just because you'll see why ok so I
really really like citrusy IPAs and I do
drink them fairly often the first time I
tried an IPA I thought I hated it it I
mean I don't remember what it was or
what kind of hops
used but like there are I would say
there's like four broad varieties of
hops so there's like citrusy hops
there's like piney ever greeny tasting
hops and then there's like continental
European hops which are slightly
slightly bitter and like I don't know
it's it's tough it's tough to describe
their flavor I guess coming up short
anyway they do have a very distinct
flavor so if you've ever had like a
German beer the hop characteristic from
that beers is what European hops tend to
taste like and then English hops which
are kind of like toasty and like for
lack of a better word like kind of like
spicy almost not like you know not like
high capsaicin content if you want a a
good example of what that what that
tastes like
try to find a good ESB they'll typically
be hopped with traditional English hops
so anyway as far as IPAs go they're
generally hopped with either the very
like evergreen e tasting hops or the
citrusy tasting hops and I only really
got into beer in who may be like
2014-2015 so I don't know like the whole
history of like IPAs at least in America
but at least when I got into drinking
them or like got into beer in general it
seemed like virtually all of the IPAs I
tried at first had kind of like the
piney Evergreen tasting hops and I just
wasn't into that and so I thought I
didn't like IPAs and then the first time
I had one that had like the citrusy
tasting hops and you know now I know
more about them I love Citra hops like
that that if I if I'm looking at an IPA
in the store and it says like it has a
[ __ ] ton of Citra hops I'm like okay
like I'm sold
need you say more and so yeah I like
citrusy IPAs possibly my favorite beer
of all time is a Duvel which may
I'm not sure if they're from Belgium I
think they are but they make Belgian
style beers they they did some limited
runs of their their typical triple with
different hop varietals in it and so we
got the the Deauville triple hop Citra
beer and my god it was delicious
I thought it was just a new thing I got
super excited turned out to be a limited
run I was deeply disappointed but yeah
citrusy and like hazy juicy New England
style IPAs or just any style of IPA with
citrusy hops very very good stuff
probably my favorite general style of
beer which and these are the ones I
don't drink super often are Belgian
triples and quads and the reason I don't
drink them very often is they're very
calorie dense and very boozy and I'm
like theoretically trying to cut and so
I'm not interested in drinking a 12
ounce beer that has like 370 calories or
something like that and also like dude
when I turn like 25
I went from never getting hangovers to
like kind of getting hangovers a little
bad and so if I drink like one quad
that's like 12% ABV I'm not gonna be
hungover the next morning but I will I
will feel a little off from just one and
like you know that's fine on on occasion
but that's not how I want to go about
living my life so yeah I don't drink
triples and quads very often but when
it's a night that it's like okay like
I'm gonna have a few beers I'm gonna cut
loose it's gonna be a good time you know
[ __ ] the macros then triples and quads
are probably my favourite beer style but
like I said I just love beer so citrusy
IPAs and Belgian triples and quads those
are those are definitely my go-to s but
really the only beer style I just
generally don't like are sours like I
just never got into them and I don't
know dude like they just don't vibe with
me and kind of the other
popular style that I don't dislike them
but I would almost always pick anything
else over them our Porter's so I I like
a good stout
I like the toasted malt but for whatever
reason like toasted malt with like
pretty aggressive hopping and I don't
know like I when I taste toasted malt I
won't the whole flavor to be pretty
intense
so like Porter's just just generally
don't cut it for me
so I don't know the technical like like
the technical point when Porter's end
and stouts begin but I've had some damn
good Imperial Porter's which to me read
as a stout but ya know I'm not crazy
about Porter's but yeah I'll [ __ ] with
pretty much any other beer style and it
depends what kind of mood I'm in so if I
just came back from like I don't know
like playing basketball in the summer
got really sweaty or like I did some
yard work and I'm really overheated like
at that point I don't know I kind of
just want like a cheap shitty lite beer
like that that will hit the spot in a
way that like you like a quad certainly
wanted to do it for me right then you
know what I mean yeah so yeah there
there's a time and place for pretty much
any other beer style citrusy IPAs and
triples and quads are my favorite and
sours are the only one that I really
just generally don't like and I'm not
crazy about Porter's but anything else
like if it's beer I'll drink it
how about you yeah so I'm a little bit
more picky with beer I think the types
of beers I like are a little bit more my
beer list is a little bit more
restrictive so I love IPAs big-time so
in the winter like you mentioned
sometimes there are different scenarios
where you want a certain type of beer
but for me all scenarios lead to some
kind of IPA so like in the colder months
I love to have like an extremely piney
IPA like I wanted to feel like I wedged
a straw into a pine tree and I'm like
drinking from that
in the winter I also do I will say you
got me on two triples and quads which I
like a lot now in the summer when it's
time for kind of a more refreshing
lighter flavor that's when I like a lot
of citrusy IPAs I've had some really
good IPAs that have like a little hint
of grapefruit or a little hint of like
there's a twenty-first amendment brewery
makes like a blood orange IPA that I
love oh really really good but yeah one
of the cool things about beer given that
we're in North Carolina though is really
really good beer scene in the state
particularly in Asheville and so like
you know I love Sierra Nevada New
Belgium I think they both have a place
in Asheville I know at least New Belgium
does yeah
there's also a place there called
thirsty monk that I love and you
mentioned like one of your favorite
beers ever was like a limited run you
told me to try one of the the beers at
thirsty monk the green monk yeah and
it's like one of the best beers I've
ever had that is also a limited time run
that thing's never gonna happen again
it's never gonna happen or it's area was
seasonal no my understanding it was a
one-time partnership between two
different breweries and I don't think
it's ever gonna happen again man that
was so good
dude the last time I went there to
Asheville I specifically stopped by
there and I was like give me as much of
it as a person can legally buy at once
and they're like bro that stuff gone and
I'm probably not coming back that's
rough yeah so light life is like that
sometimes unfortunately but but yeah
IPAs for me are definitely the way to go
and and some triples and quads on top of
that and one of the cool things about
beer is that it can it kind of overlaps
with my other favorite thing in life
which is statistics so very brief story
time
so William Gossett was was employed at
the Guinness brewery and he was a
chemist and a brewer and a statistician
he actually developed the T distribution
and the t-test for it's not like oh did
you know some guy who likes to brew beer
invented the t-test it's like no he did
it for beer so like that was all
developed at the Guinness brewery to
facilitate their beer testing process
so the t-test in the t-distribution
completely revolutionized statistics at
the time a huge impact huge lasting
impact on how we do research and analyze
data and yes I want to give the story
for why we've referred to it as students
t-test yes yes so you might be thinking
well every other stat procedure I know
is somebody's name but but I've never
heard of the gosset t-test right and so
it's called the student t-test because
when he was employed at Guinness he a
clause in his contract basically
indicated you are developing stuff at
our brewery on our dime and so you can't
just be freely publishing that stuff
wherever you want like that belongs to
Guinness and so basically like he kind
of just like leaked it and just said
like yeah I'm just gonna write under the
name student like like some just generic
name and so so my understanding of the
story is that's basically why it was
called students t-test that was because
he was like well I can't call it my name
because then I'm gonna get fired yeah
you know so a cool thing about him
though I was like I would imagine
largely because he had to do some of
that stuff like kind of like leak and
stuff here and there for whatever reason
he a rare thing about him is he was
friends with both Pierson and Fisher who
were like two pillars and statistics at
the time but hated each other like the
the idea that someone could be friends
with both of them is kind of a miracle
like it's you wonder how it worked out
because they hated each other so much
but just to get an idea of this sense of
the time like you've got Gossett
developing the t-test
you've got Pearson like you've heard of
a Pearson correlation that's him he also
did the first thing resembling a
meta-analysis which actually led to an
erroneous conclusion which is a fun
historical fact
so whenever everyone acts like meta
analyses are these like perfect thing
that are the absolute top tier evidence
it's like yeah but sometimes they're
wrong so keep that in mind but he also
Pearson's been credited for kind of
formally introducing the use of p-values
I'm sure someone who's more tapped into
the history is like well actually you
know it's more complicated than that but
these are kind of the late
historical highlights and then Fisher
you know it's largely credited for
helping develop the analysis of variance
which is open up any strength or
nutrition journal you're gonna see a
nova in there big time so just a really
interesting time where a lot of these
foundational things were happening with
statistics and like all good things it
leads back to beer you love to hear it
you love to hear it alright I think that
about does it for this episode people
have been asking when are normal
episodes going to come back we are still
making regular episodes of the podcast
the next one will be coming out this
Thursday so you know be on the lookout
for that fireside chats are something we
are doing in addition to regular podcast
episodes they're not supplanting them so
yeah be on the lookout there is another
normal podcast episode coming out this
Thursday hopefully I will be allowed to
be a temporary guest host on it but we
will just see anyway that about does it
thank you for listening if you have a
question or topic you would like us to
discuss either on the normal podcast or
on a future fireside chat you can ask it
at tiny dot CC /sb sqa looking forward
to hearing from you if you're listening
on youtube like comment subscribe
[ __ ] hate myself deal with it if you
like the podcast rated on itunes or
wherever you get your podcast and yeah
hope things are going well stay safe and
we'll talk to you soon
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com to check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you